Washington's governor is expected to ban
gatherings of more than 250 people in
most of the Seattle metro area the state
thinks it could get tens of thousands
more cases of corona virus
public health officials say at least ten
long-term care facilities in the Seattle
area have reported cases patients have
died at three of those facilities
Jonathan Vigliotti is outside the Life
Care Center in Kirkland Washington the
epicenter of that outbreak Jonathan how
severe is the problem yeah and Anthony
to put in perspective just how
vulnerable the elderly are of the 32
confirmed deaths around the country 20
of them are linked to this nursing home
all of this as now state officials here
concerned as well as residents remain on
edge this is how Bridgette Parkhill and
her sister now visit their mother who
recently tested positive for corona
virus at the Life Care Center in
Kirkland how did you process that it
wasn't a shock that she was positive it
should have been a priority to get
everybody tested so they could get all
the negative people out of here before
they turn positive but a shortage of
tests meant only the critically ill were
prioritized at least 11 other long-term
care facilities in Washington including
the Josephine caring community now have
infected residents or staff the facility
isn't locked down so no visitors no
consultants and no families and I can
tell you that's incredibly tough in
Northern California
officials confirm Tuesday that an
assisted-living resident in their 90s
died there a recent study examining
coronavirus cases in China found that in
people over 80 years old the death rate
was nearly 15% in Seattle's King County
74 more cases were announced Tuesday
bringing the statewide total some more
than 260 if you do the math and gets
very disturbing governor jay Inslee
outlined new rules for nursing homes
including limiting patients to one
visitor per day and screening employees
and volunteers for symptoms at the start
of their shift the
people who are infected in an epidemic
like this will double in the state of
Washington unless we take some some real
action here and if you have a loved one
in a nursing home or facility like this
experts have some recommendations they
say call the facility check on their
staffing and their cleaning procedures
they're also recommending keeping your
distance call or use face time if
possible and if you have a loved one
inside keep them they're experts say it
could be risky to remove them at this
point
Tony Jonathan thank you very much